all right i did a tweet what's going on
with oculus is anybody actually using
these and i just pointed out
a trend i see all the time and i didn't
mean any offense the oculus team by the
way this is not specific to oculus it's
really about vr but oculus is the leader
so i i i mentioned them so again
apologies to anybody at oculus who took
this personal i know palmer lucky uh the
founder of oculus who is no longer at
oculus
liked one of the rebuttals to my tweet
but here's the tweet i said every person
i know who has bought an oculus uses it
for a couple of days they won't shut up
about it for one week and then they
never bring it up again
which is to say they stopped using it
explain slash name this pattern
i named it the oculus try oh my and
goodbye so i was being a little cheeky
maybe a little sharp elbowed uh ryan
engel whose twitter bio reads creator of
topgolf with pro put for oculus golf
scope founder and ceo former cto of
wikiby extremely bullish on vr responded
not according to our usage metrics real
data is greater than twitter anecdotes
however if people you know didn't buy it
to game then it's probably right it's
primarily a glimpse into the future for
non-gamers we skew older golf averaging
because i asked the follow-up question
like who who's using it
and he said averaging around 30 to 40
years old mostly male but apparently a
higher female percentage compared to
most vr games our game is very social
and pretty relaxing
so i think it's a nice escape my 65 year
old dad has been playing uh delhi for a
year he also noted someone can say they
hate vr but the data says they play 10
hours a week yadda yadda
and so i responded i thought this was a
very interesting insight because almost
everybody i know who's bought one of
these headsets from oculus
uh which is the leader and they're
really affordable and they're super
impressive like that's why i was saying
people get really excited about and then
stop using it so i'm just wondering out
loud why that is
the people i know who bought these were
all pc gamers like they were intense
gamers and i think
the issue is if you're an intense gamer
and you really like pc games or console
games
i think
vr is not as good it's not as good of an
experience so if you've got a lot of
gaming enthusiasm and you're really the
tip of the spear
i think vr is a step back for you it's
not as engaging uh you might like
playing saber or whatever dancing saber
one or you might like this golf one
but
um i came up with another theory
because then there's the people who play
casual games right and there's many more
casual gamers on phones playing
bejeweled or
cut the rope or angry birds or you know
candy crush you know all these games
farmville i think those people might
also be interested in vr but it's not
portable in the same way right
so who is the audience
well
i thought this was interesting so i
really appreciated the response i got
back
from ryan
about
golf and we should book him for the show
by the way uh producer justin
they
what they've explained i think is listen
playing golf on a pc or playing golf on
your ipad those experiences might not be
that fun right do you want to play golf
on your pc or golf on your iphone i
don't think so
but the real world golf that's hard you
got to get you got to book a tee time
it's massively expensive
so that if you were considering golf
versus like real world golf versus
vr golf
vr golf is cheap and easy and fun when
compared to real world golf it's much
cheaper it's much easier you don't have
to get in a car
and it's a lot of fun so maybe there's
something about real world activities
that are expensive and hard to do
mountain climbing scuba diving skiing
i'm thinking out loud here flying an
airplane uh hang gliding you know maybe
you even include dangerous in this
so things that are dangerous and
expensive that maybe only rich people
can do or that are you know take a lot
of coordination maybe those are perfect
for vr because vr is about creating a
world well if you're doing a first
person shooter or you're playing you
know diablo whatever game you're into
for at night
maybe that doesn't work as well but
these other things do
so i thought this was kind of uh
interesting a frequent source of scoops
on twitter and facebook features jane
wong aka wong m jane worth following
frequently posts playing the game beat
saber which is kind of like guitar hero
with lightsabers and i actually played
this we bought two of the new oculus my
kids loved it we used it for a week and
it's been sitting collecting dust ever
since and i think i paid 50 bucks for it
but my lord beat saber is awesome that
is a very fun game and i think that's
like another perfect example you really
when you do go fencing or something you
really can't
play a star wars lightsaber game and
what an amazing thing beat saber would
be if you could play obi-wan or darth
maul or if you could battle other people
and you could use have the ipa of
obi-wan teaching you you know there's a
specific style that obi-wan and qui-gon
jin used versus
ashoka tana and according to some of our
live listeners here facebook bought
beatsaber and uh there apparently is
another game vader immortal which is uh
actually licensed properly for those of
you who are asking if you own ip the
reason you see these lawsuits so
frequently in fact lucasfilm uh back in
2016 sued some jedi school uh because
they were training people in lightsabers
the reason
ip owners have to do this is is because
if you don't the lawyers tell you if you
don't sue somebody for infringing on
your trademark then
some really bad actor can use your
trademark and point to the times you
didn't sue other people and say well you
didn't stop them
and they did more infringing or did
equal infringing therefore you can't
stop up so it's either you protect it or
you lose it you protect your ip or you
lose it so anyway
basically with this vr stuff my personal
belief is
that the headsets are too heavy
too cumbersome and
the other options out there for gaming
are too compelling and that the software
is just not there yet in other words i
think they've solved the platform
problem
you know there's a big enough platform
out here i think they solved
monetization because people who have
these will pay 50 bucks 25 bucks for
these games i did other people will but
it should be a little cheaper and i
think the software hasn't um
found
uh hasn't been refined enough so i think
you know beat saber
and rec room are the two that people
really like i think it's gonna take
another
maybe three revisions two or three
revisions on the software for somebody
to make something that is so compelling
that a million or two million people a
day want to use it and i think when you
get a million people playing a social
game per day as opposed to per month i
think rec room says they have a million
active users when you start to get
millions of active users per day and
when you show up to play a game it
really becomes uh interesting so it does
feel like we're on the cusp
with vr and i wonder if vr the headsets
are just too heavy too expensive too
clunky
you know the fear of tripping over
animals in your house children bumping
into stuff
and that may be ar
if you could pay beat sabers on google
ar glasses and you see the beats coming
to you and you can see your friends
around that would be super interesting
but i do give oculus a lot of credit the
latest headset
that doesn't need to be plugged in or
synced with your phone is dynamite but
the games
are not as compelling as ipad games and
pc games and console games so that's
where i think the investment has to come
in but we'll see i think the metaverse
is a bit of a bust i think the real
world is more fun
if your bank charges outrageous fees you
need a bank account that's built for
small businesses you need to check out
novo's free business banking platform
novo is built from the ground up to be
powerful yet simple and provide free
business banking you heard that correct
there are no minimum balances there are
no transaction limits and there's no
hidden fees that's why money magazine
called novo the best business checking
account in 2021.
novo makes banking easy and secure you
can manage your account and their
customizable website and use their apps
novo's web apps have built in profit
first accounting and invoicing you can
easily tag each transaction and upload
your receipts easy breezy
lemon squeezy novo seamlessly integrates
with most leading business tools and
services like strife i use that shopify
we use that quickbooks we've used that
and more for free they also offer five
thousand dollars in perks and discounts
just for signing up so get your free
business banking account in just 10
minutes at
banknovo.com
twist you'll also get a novo debit card
for free atm use and a free copy of novo
small business starter guide once again
banknovo.com twist that's
b-a-n-k-n-o-v-o dot com slash t-w-i-s-t
to open your banking account in just 10
minutes give it a shot it's amazing